stand before Allah and he said to you
why he did not accept Islam what's a
reason you think you will say it to
Allah and you think will be valid
but Allah is no reason except shaytan
and let me ask you if you know someone
is your worst enemy would you follow him
so this is Satan's our worst enemy you
know we have like in our bodies there's
two there's angel and devil the answer
that wants you to accept the truth but
the devil shall stop you so will lie I
know maybe if you bring like under
pressure or something no you know many
times you do evil things up in front of
everyone you're gonna accept the truth
You're Gonna Worship your creator the
one you've been cutting off Allah is
better off to become Muslim today when
you leave hamdulillah and I've been
doing this for 15 years never it's my
brother with me all the time I will tell
you never someone except Islam and he
came back said you know what brother
he's a Rivers he became 17.
I understand so don't let stop you guys
look yourself you know that you have no
excuse you have no reason for not
accepting Islam Today